tu sais que quand j'étais plus jeune je
voulais faire Philippe Risoli mais je
sais mais je te jure j'étais mon
animateur mais c'est pour ça que je
t'avais repéré dans le public parce que
je me suis lui il veut faire moi c'est
toujours ouais c'est vrai parce que on
va on va revenir sur cette extrait tout
de suite comme ça c'est fait c'est vrai
que tu as animé Le juste prix célèbre
jeu et en fait il y a des potes j'avais
18 ans et il y a des potes qui m'ont dit
on va faire un kiff on va aller au juste
prix c'était dans le public et en fait
pour le juste prix vous passez devant
tout le public arrive et en fait il y a
des gens des gens du casting qui disent
tiens lui on va peut-être le faire jouer
lui aussi et donc j'étais avec plusieurs
potes et on voyait qu'on avait pas été
sélectionné donc on s'est dit on va
le bordel dans le public et en
fait c'était étonnant il enregistrait au
départ c'était la finale et après on
faisait les autres jours de la semaine
il enregistré la finale et il y avait un
mec qui avait gagné plein de trucs donc
il est Numéris à chaque fois ce qu'il
avait gagné le mec donc à chaque fois il
disait je sais pas un mini a choisi
et engueuler comme des fois et un moment
il y a Philippe qui voit des ouf entre
algueuler qui fait venez là tous les
deux j'étais avec mon ami Olivier qui
était
lui qui commençait à travailler déjà il
était vous allez voir il était
commercial et voir la cravate avec tout
de suite comprendre il y avait une
cravate avec des téléphones donc voilà
et c'est vrai que Philippe je suis
rentré chez moi j'ai dit à ma mère j'ai
parlé à Philippe Risoli ma carrière est
lancée et que le jour que c'est mignon
je te le jure en fait c'était pas faux
finalement c'est important
Philippe je te jure c'est que ça c'est
un souvenir incroyable et j'étais
reparti avec un livre des records c'est
bien je l'ai gardé je l'ai toujours je
le disais tous les soirs je connais tous
les records le mec qui casse les deux
des noix avec son cul tout ça je le
connais regarde c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous montrer pour venir tous les
deux oui tous les deux venez venez alors
vous allez me faire la même ambiance on
va faire un petit interview de Carlos si
vous faites la même ambiance que celle
que vous mettez dans le public
actuellement Carlos bonjour Vous venez
d'où Carlos vous avez un de
Berre-l'Étang
et vous avez gagné quoi cette semaine
Carlos j'ai gagné un caméscope
[Applaudissements]
et un équipement d'équitation d'accord
incroyable mais pour moi c'était du pain
béni d'avoir des des gens comme toi et
ton pote là
je te jure je te jure que je repasse
tu as démarré ta carrière sur Canal+ a
été chez nous tu étais dans le groupe
c'est ça 10 février 86 un jeu déjà
regardé
j'ai fini j'ai regardé tout ce que tu as
fait tu étais mon animateur préféré je
te le jure et vraiment regarde on a
retrouvé les images faire Queen
Alexandra bonsoir d'abord Alexandra dit
Olivier a gagné 34 en 1500 francs il
fait oui oui oui j'ai gagné ils vont se
dire plus de 500 et c'est notre champion
Olivier lui opposant ce soir Bérengère
et l'autre baie de la soirée sera
Bernard pour le départage tout à l'heure
on fera l'émission 3 invités vedettes
nous avons eu Kaby lors du récent
starfouls dernier star quiz c'est
Dorothée qui vient de me rejoindre ce
soir
nous jouons également avec
Marie-christine de bourse coucou
[Musique]
et puis et enfin avec Enrique le voici
voilà
[Musique]
pas le sujet et puis de raconter comment
un petit gars comme moi du 18e
arrondissement des HLM de la ville de
Paris arrivent à se faufiler finalement
en faisant des trucs un peu
invraisemblable personne ne savait par
exemple que j'avais été l'assistante de
Sim tu te souviens de Sim voilà donc
sur une émission et je vois la je
raconte un tas de souvenirs comme ça et
ça me permet de toucher un tas de sujets
qui sont aussi bien je te dis là cette
période de la guerre où mon grand-père a
failli se faire pondre un jour par la
foule en délire ça me permet de parler
de l'euthanasie ça me permet de parler
de parler de la cigarette parce que j'ai
j'ai
une petite raconter une anecdote sur le
juste prix avec la cigarette justement
Mathieu bah tu veux qu'on voit bah vas-y
fais-le maintenant
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque je fumais
quand même pas mal j'avais pris
l'habitude avec mes collaborateurs quand
on faisait une coupe de d'allumer une
cigarette et mais sauf que j'avais pas
le temps de la terminer alors je me
disais bon au début je l'ai balancé dans
un cendrier puis au bout d'un moment je
suis je vais les écraser puis je la
rallumerai le tu et pendant des semaines
et des semaines j'ai fumé ma cigarette
on reprenait il y avait une coupure on
reprenait j'écrasé ma signature talent
je la mettais dans la poche de mon
pantalon et allons-y bonjour à tous
juste pris sauf qu'un jour je l'ai mal
éteint
et donc
[Rires]
j'arrive chez bonjour à tous bienvenue
sur le plateau
ça m'a brûlé la cuisse au troisième
degré mais mon pantalon c'est quasiment
enflammé il s'est mis à se consumer les
gens qui étaient dans le public face à
moi c'est le mec il est drôle il
est il est incroyable
[Rires]
juste prix non c'était pas dans juste
prix d'ailleurs c'est dans le
millionnaire un millionnaire
millionnaire
quand tu avais trois télés sont passés à
la télé qu'est-ce que je faisais moi non
il faut pas le faire mais moi je vous
dis les tickets de millionnaire il faut
millionnaire
faut pas le dire ça y est c'est
pas le faire faut pas le faire mais
est-ce qu'il faut pas les trois télé en
fait moi j'avais fait un truc où j'ai
essayé de faire vraiment 3 télé tu vois
et voilà je l'ai revendais 10 balles au
lycée
et les mecs passent jamais à la télé
j'ai bâillé doit avoir une erreur voilà
regarde aussi mort que qui fait son
entrée sur le plateau du millionnaire
bonjour Marc je suis obligé parce que
c'est le règlement de vous dire que vous
avez le choix entre deux boules
franchement
[Rires]
et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
candidats et de candidats très drôles
ont fait une petite compile quand tu
revois tout ça Philippe est-ce que la
télé te manque pas du tout ça y est
quand tu fais ce métier comme tu le fais
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire
comme vous le faites évidemment que tu
as ça dans la peau je veux dire que tu
dis pas un moment bah tiens je vais
arrêter je vais passer à autre chose tu
ne passes jamais à autre chose ah bah
non non pas tu ne peux jamais autre
chose je fais d'autre chose je fais du
théâtre j'écris ce livre je fais plein
de trucs si tu veux mais tu peux tu peux
pas te dire non moi je reste
téléspectateur comme je l'étais de la
façon dont parmi je te regarde si ça me
plaît pas je zappe je passe sur autre
chose je connais pratiquement tout tous
les programmes alors quand Gilles parle
que j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
dans différentes manifestations qui
d'ailleurs je le dois dire n'est pas
tout à fait le même en extérieur de hein
c'est quand on demande à l'intérieur
c'est ton amour mais Philippe comment ça
s'est arrêté je me rappelle plus en fait
ça s'est arrêté pour toi alors là là là
la fin du juste prix c'est 2001 ça
c'était prévu puisque c'est l'arrivée de
l'euro donc on s'est retrouvé à estimé
des cadeaux en euros ça ça donnait un
peu compliqué il fallait absolument
faire un break sauf que alors je vais
produire encore mais
sauf que j'avais un j'avais plusieurs
projet j'étais sur plusieurs projets
d'émission soit une variété mais est
arrivé la Star Academy donc ça me ça me
coupait la route de la variété qui
pourtant était initialement prévu soit
une émission caritative puisque mon boss
de l'époque me disait était un type
était fédérateur on t'écoute quand tu te
mets à parler tu emmènes les gens avec
toi on va faire une émission le dimanche
après-midi et pour les associations pour
voilà et ça va se passer et puis en fait
ça s'est pas passé comme ça donc à ce
moment-là c'est vrai que ça devient un
peu compliqué mais ça je le raconterai
dans dans la suite je raconte attention
avec aucune aigreur aucun mais je vais
le raconter avec humour mais je
raconterai par exemple la façon dont tu
fais partie de ce métier invité à toutes
les premières ton premier rang si tu
viens pas on pourquoi t'es pas là avec
du sois là des deux places vite fait
absolument que tu viennes puis bon du
jour au lendemain alors pendant un
certain temps tu es encore invité parce
que quand on arrive à ton niveau combien
à l'époque on se dit rebondir tu vois il
va revenir donc on préserve un petit peu
la suite tu vois puis à un moment tu es
encore invité mais là tu es plus au 4e
rente et
aussi tu recules si tu veux fur et à
mesure du temps tu recul et puis à un
moment tu es plus invité et puis tu dis
merde j'aurais bien vu ce alors tu
passes un petit coup de fil mais la
personne est plus là tu arrives plus à
l'avoir donc tu vois et je pourrais
presque faire des sketchs la sucette
c'est drôle je vais te dire et là la
fois où j'ai dit c'est fini je veux même
plus être invité je paierai mes places
et un jour je suis invité pour une pièce
de théâtre mais au Théâtre de la gaieté
Montparnasse pour ceux qui le
connaissent il y a un pylône il y a un
gros pylône et je me retrouve deux
places derrière le pylône tu vois et
j'ai donc je passe mon temps tu vois que
comme ça c'est pas possible tu vois mais
à contrario je me dis pareil pour le
foot avec Canal tu vois j'avais mal lol
j'étais invitation un malade de foot je
t'invite à tous les matchs tu vois sauf
que là tu es plus invité à étudier
attends j'ai de quoi me payer une place
pour aller au foot donc tu vas au foot
mais là tu es plus en officiel tu es
plus au présidentiel tu te retrouves
avec ton public qui est très sympathique
le public sauf que quand tu es là avec
ton fils pour regarder un français et
que derrière tu as deux allumés qui te
hurle dans les oreilles là mais il est
oh là là
tu te casses tu dis je vais le regarder
à la télé donc c'est sûr que tu as un
petit bouleversement quand même dans ta
vie mais je tiens à préciser que je peux
écouter tes anecdotes comme ça et bah tu
peux mais ça sera un deuxième livre
maintenant je veux écouter Philippe
brésilien rester avec nous franchement
j'adore je sais que j'adore des
histoires comme ça bah tu me racontes
d'autres histoires même là sur TF1 et
tout parce que toi tu faisais des tu
faisais des cartes ton audience tu
faisais combien ouais pour te donner un
ordre d'idée le juste prix la finale du
dimanche c'était aux alentours de 12
millions
le millionnaire c'était des 6-7000 tu
sais si attends il y a pas de secret si
je suis resté populaire alors que tu
peux allumer ta télé je participerai
rarement à des émissions tu me vois pas
en fait parfois je suis invité mais
maintenant j'écoute me le dire j'y vais
pour de bonnes raisons j'ai pas envie
d'être là si attendre
alors qu'est-ce que je te raconte 12
millions voilà c'était c'est la raison
pour laquelle malgré le fait qu'on ne me
voit plus je reste globalement assez
populaire parce que c'était des
audimates absolument énorme donc ça date
un peu mais heureusement pour moi ils
sont pas tous morts tu vois tu as fait
combien d'années comment tu as fait
combien d'années
au quotidien donc le 10 février 86 sur
Canal et j'ai été en quotidienne sans
interruption jusqu'au 31 août 2001 voilà
donc ça fait quand même ça fait quand
même alors ça
on parle on parle toujours même en 10 de
plus on parle toujours on parle toujours
effectivement du Juste Prix du
millionnaire mais il y a eu des gros
cartons comme succès fou que je
présentais avec Patrick Roy la nouvelle
affiche dont a parlé tout à l'heure et
d'autres encore Intervilles par exemple
intervie que j'ai des images dans un
instant le vrai avec Guy luxe
[Applaudissements]